ils représentent les quatre évangélistes
daté du xviiie siècle
ces tableaux de l'église notre-dame de
bourges sont classés monuments
historiques signés de la main de
françois nicolas mot prin il était
membre de l'académie royale de peinture
membres de l'acca limite saluc aussi
qu'ils étaient donc des institutions
renommées à l'époque il a produit aussi
pour lui 16 et on trouve nombre de ses
oeuvres principalement semble-t-il dans
le nom de l'affrontement ces quatre
tableaux se retrouver ici ça on ne sait
pas c'est en 2010 lors de travaux dans
l'ancienne sacristie que le tableau ont
été retrouvés bien endommagé les bourses
aux fleurs qu'on voit ici c'est donc
c'est les gravats qui sont mis derrière
et qui ont modifié la toile puis si on
voit une déchirure à cnet coût total
estimé de la restauration 27000 euros
l'association de sauvegarde de notre
dame de bourges a déjà rassemblé 90 % de
la somme pour les 3500 euros restants
elle a lancé à akron funding une demande
de financement participatif sur internet
à l'heure actuelle seuls 400 euros ont
pu être récoltés et on réagit pas assez
rapidement ça sera de faire empirer
donc après la facture va s'agrandir une
restauration de ses tableaux marquerait
la première étape d'un projet bien plus
important à savoir la rénovation de
l'ensemble de l'église notre dame la
restauration du bâtiment elle même du
bâtiment lui-même pardon ça représente
des centaines de milliers d'euros si
vous voulez donc comme le conservateur
des antiquités et objets historiques
souhaitée urgemment que ce chantier soit
ouvert nous avons préféré effectivement
le suivre et nous faire en même temps la
main si vous voulez sur un chantier
beaucoup plus modeste l'association a
bon espoir de pouvoir donner une seconde
jeunesse à ses oeuvres de mme au prince
elle vise une restauration complète à
l'horizon 2020
[Musique]